wer weiß schon freuen
jeder tag ist
er weiß schon heute morgen sind immer
und wieder alles neu begeht
in hamburg heute besuche ich mein
zwillingsbruder den kombinieren und wir
fahren jetzt auf die reeperbahn
schauen wir dort was es alles zu sehen
gibt
was kann man hier alles erleben ja also
von alkohol trinken über feiern über
prostitution kann man hier alles haben
was man habe hier ist natürlich auch
fußballspiele es heißt hier ist heute
auf den handel und wahnsinnig lustig für
die sanierung als im bundestag sondern
zum bebelplatz wo früher die videos
abgespielt haben hier das sind die
beatles beim musizieren
wir begeben uns jetzt auf die an ihrem
eile von hamburg bzw
pauli reeperbahn und hier erinnert
wirklich alles daran wo wir uns jetzt
befinden
selbst der ec automat der sagt ja schon
alles los gehts los geht's geben auf
geht's
reinschauen
so stellt man sich hier vor
im rotlichtbezirk
alles hier schön rot samtig und ich
glaube ihm richtig spaß
herrlich genau das richtige
sag mal kommen
diese gar nichts los ich glaube hier ist
immer erst auf den 20 uhr party oder das
denke ich mir auch aber so wie jedes
wochenende wird es hier sicher nicht
vorgestellt
hier bringen kann immer alles ich glaube
je mehr es bringt bist du mir lockt das
muss natürlich auch immer eine sache die
türsteher die dann leute ansprechen
es geht auf und wir immer wieder die
stadt paris kopfprämie bleibe alles live
show die große sause
doch geht es ab 20 uhr geht werden wir
meinen hübsche besitzer vor der
überzeugung gekommen
eine ganz wichtige steht nach hier auf
dem kiez die herbertstraße wir dürfen
rein und ich sind jetzt endlich ankommen
in der herbertstraße wir schauen mal
rein
aber wir schauen auch wirklich nur hier
muss leider draußen bleiben
aber wir zählen dann gleich wie es war
ganz ehrlich nicht für mich